Some of the promised benefits of
Network Virtualization are more rapid innovation since
innovation can proceed at the rate at
which software evolves. Rather on hardware development
cycles, allowing for new forms of network
control, and potentially simplifying programming. It is
important to make a distinction between Network
Virtualization and Software-Defined Networking. Network Virtualization is
arguably one of the first killer applications for
SDN. And in some sense, SDN is a
tool for implementing Network virtualization. But the two
are not one in the same. Remember the
defining tenant of SDN is the separation of
the data and control plant, whereas the defining
tenant of Network virtualization. Is to separate the
underlying physical network from the logical networks that
lie on top of it. So SDN can be used to simplify many aspects of
Network virtualization. But it does not inherently
obstruct the details of the underlying physical network.